تحديد اللاعبين ليس جديده في كره القدم
ووصل احيانا لنهايات ماساويه فقبل نحو 28
عاما كان اللاعب الكولومبي الراحل اندرياس
اسكوبار على موعد مع عده رصاصات غادره
خرجت من عناصر في المافيا الكولومبيه اثر
تسببه بهدف في مرمى بلاده خرج على اثره
المنتخب من كاس العالم امريكا عام
1994 وايضا في كولومبيا تلقى لاعب وسط
المنتخب كارلوس سانشيز تهديدات بالقتل عقب
تسببه في ضربه جزاء ضد المنتخب والخساره
امام اليابان لكن الشرطه تدخلت لحمايته
وعدم تكرار الماساه عدو التهديد انتقلت
اوروبا فها هو لاعب منتخب الدنمارك نيكولا
جون يتعرض لتهديد بعد اهداره لضربه جزاء
امام كرواتيا للخروج من كاس العالم
النجم الاسباني سيرجيو راموس كان قد تعرض
لعده تهديدات بالقتل بعد اصابته لمنتخب
لكابتن منتخب مصر محمد صلاح في نهائي دوري
ابطال اوروبا عام 2018